but first America in shutdown day 14 now
I want to start with the raw numbers
alright let's keep it up here guys
alright more than 160,000 Americans have
tested positive for the corona virus
that's out of nine hundred and
forty-four thousand who have been tested
just in the last month nearly 3,000
people have died of course New York is
still a hot zone although the state's
rate of new infections thankfully is
beginning to level off it's a very good
sign and we are going to bring you new
details on this as the show continues
now let's look at the numbers all right
could the infections there be nearing a
peak maybe or let's keep keep keep going
here Colorado may be showing a similar
sense of promise we'll talk about this
tonight as well but LA and parts of
South Florida are spiking as more tested
and more hospitalized those numbers look
very disturbing now the FDA fast-tracked
this was great news they fast-tracked
approval for the emergency use of the
drug that we just mentioned first two
weeks ago tonight to the cable TV
audience in the United States you'd
never heard of hydroxychloroquine before
we mentioned it this is terrific news
the pharmaceutical company Sanders has
been working with us very closely and as
Alex mentioned a little bit 30 million
doses of the hydroxychloroquine to the
United States government it's been given
and bear has donated 1 million doses of
the chloroquine tepa Pharmaceuticals is
also donating 6 million doses of
hydroxychloroquine to US hospitals now
we have exciting new developments in the
private sector regarding immunity
testing as well which would give us
critical information namely who among us
won't ever get covert 19 because of a
natural or developed immunity to it that
is incredible now those folks people who
have that
you could obviously go back to work that
would be good for all of us but of
course many of you and I know you were
because I heard from you were
crestfallen to hear the president's
decision last night to extend this
national shutdown to at least at least
April 30th and Virginia Governor Ralph
Northam he announced he's closing down
the state until June 10th acknowledging
today that this would have a devastating
impact on the state's economy he said
it's going to be really hard ya think
yes it is it's going to be really hard
Maryland is closed indefinitely Governor
Hogan's stay-at-home order doesn't
specify any end date there so people are
wondering when will life ever get back
to normal now at the daily briefing
today
a few moments stood out Scott Gottlieb
your former FDA Commissioner wrote a
roadmap for recovery after the
coronavirus suicide he suggests the the
roadmap suggest that everybody wear a
mask in public is that something that
the task force thinks is a good idea
you haven't discussed it to that extent
but it's certainly something we could
discuss we're not going to be wearing
masks forever but it could be for a
short period of time after we get back
into gear okay wait a second now
remember when didn't he tell us not to
use masks or buy masks and that that has
completely changed I guess we're
learning new things all the time
everyone's gonna have to wear a mask for
the foreseeable future we need clearer
guidelines there now the former FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb has the
president's ear he's highly respected by
many including dr. Anthony foutch II he
sits on a number of big pharma boards
there's nothing wrong with that and he
works at a very prominent think-tank the
American Enterprise in Washington now
every American especially those who are
interested in making plans for the
future should carefully read what Scott
Gottlieb is advocating Visa Visa
coronavirus now one of the things he
said he breaks it down into four phases
it's kind of interesting but one of the
things he says right now we're in phase
one and phase one is
is essentially trying to you know
contain this mitigate this do what we're
doing now phase two would be more
stepped-up you know social distancing
but maybe we could you know slowly pull
back in a few states we'll see where
that goes it also mentions the tracking
of US citizens now this was actually
brought up in the briefing today it were
where the government I guess would use
GPS trackers again this isn't Scott
Gottlieb's list of proposals to get us
back to normal now what do you think of
that GPS tracking of US citizens to
enforce the stay at home or the social
distancing orders now we expected that
from Russia and China what the United
States use those measures the president
when he responded today said well that's
pretty severe but he also said they you
know they understand he's he's heard
about this report maybe he's read their
report we all understand as this is
going forward that the president has a
lot of balancing air he's getting a lot
of inputs from a lot of people lot of
smart people and we understand he needs
to protect the lives of Americans that's
critically important health care workers
now think about them they're feeling the
strain you've seen them on television
that's real in many parts of the country
not all parts but many parts the stress
the anxiety the worry the personal
protective gear some of them still don't
have enough and some are getting sick
themselves that's really really
terrifying can't break the system we all
get that and tonight we also know that
the economic carnage is piling up as
well now it's already being felt
coast-to-coast having its own
devastating impact on working men and
women on their children on the elderly
on the at-risk and low-income families
there especially especially in harm's
way now now again gottlieb breaks down
our recovery into those three phases i
talked about early right really right
now we're in phase one and phase two
would be able to get on a modified track
states who have the outbreak under
control could
slowly start to reopen schools and
businesses parks but would still have to
practice some social distancing limiting
large gatherings keeping the elderly and
the vulnerable somewhat isolated now in
this phase testing would also need to be
more routine and widespread than it is
today
it seems kind of reasonable but who
knows how long that would take we are
testing more than any other country in
the world now not by per capita
standards but we've just jacked that up
Alexei czars done a great job all other
people the White House have stepped in
but is this goal to get even to phase
two is it achievable by April 30th is it
achievable by June 30th there are a lot
of things in this document so what would
it take for America then you might ask
if it phase two it's not even clear to
get back to normal life the life you had
before all this you know those days when
kids actually went to school and people
went to sporting events and graduations
and weddings and restaurants and church
okay here's during phase three this is
from the Gottlieb recommendations
physical distancing restrictions and
other phase two measures can be lifted
when safe and effective tools for
mitigating the risk of kovat 19 are
available including broad surveillance
therapeutics or a safe and effective
vaccine that goes back to the GPS
tracking now we all want a vaccine we're
praying for a vaccine
brilliant brilliant people are working
on that right now but Anthony foul she
told us that would be at least 12 months
from now if not 18 months that's how
long the process takes
today Johnson & Johnson a lot announced
plans for a clinical trial of a kovat 19
vaccine in September that's when the
trial would begin but let me be clear if
Gottlieb's metrics are going to be the
ones the White House uses and thinking
about this and talking to a lot of other
really smart people today Congress needs
to come back into session like tomorrow
okay if all of our scientific resources
are needed to get this vaccine
tested done designed and ready to go as
soon as possible so we can go back to
being a free country if that's the
metric then we all need to know that now
it's not like at the end of April we're
told another two months no no if we need
to know that hard news I think people
need to know this news tonight in
Congress has to have to be here to help
figure this out now Americans I think
are extremely understanding they want to
do their part we all do but and just
talking to a lot of folks today from all
different locks at the walks of life
people's patience is not going to last
forever you can't blame them they're
under enormous amount of stress and they
don't have jobs Congress needs to get
involved get the actual specific metrics
that the administration is using to
determine when we can have our country
back in every one of the states also now
under a stay in place order
there should be an urgent meeting of the
state legislatures the governor should
be required to explain in every state in
detail the factual and legal basis for
his or her actions they might be
perfectly valid they might be based on
all the perfect projections and data and
if the projections are even worse than
we thought we the people have a right to
know it's only fair
give us the facts give us the metrics
for restarting the country then we can
decide whether they're achievable in a
reasonable amount of time some people
are going to lose their homes many are
gonna lose their businesses and others
they're gonna lose everything they work
their entire lives for they deserve to
have a complete understanding of the
actions being taken by the government
one of my favorite emails the day came
from an old high school friend I hadn't
heard from him I don't think it may be
17 or 18 years Laura just as scared as
anyone about coronavirus but we don't
have much of a democracy if every
difficult decision is made by
technocrats and the media and the people
and their representatives have no say in
the matter I thought about that a lot I
guess I couldn't really blame them
protect your health
and that of others wash your hands a lot
use a glove to touch outside surfaces
socially distance it's appropriate the
right thing to do help those around you
who are homebound or just depressed
there's a lot of lonely people out there
as well but let's also remember that
capitalism will and is frankly
delivering the therapies and we hope in
the future the cures for this wretched
virus so let's not kill the free market
in the process of killing the virus
every time a company closes the
floodgate of anxiety and pain is open
for its workers we want to stay safe and
free and those are my thoughts on the
end of shutdown day 14